Hello freak bitches for them.
But there's been a bit of an interesting development with ms Sarkeys and if you
like to hear about it, well tell people who she is.
I don't even even know if I need to, but most people don't know.
You live in a very insulated world like straight my mom who, Oh yeah,
your mum note, but frequency. Yeah. Yeah, of course your mum won't know. Uh,
okay. Any Stuckey's in is uh, an internet feminist who decided, uh,
after after making a bunch of videos on her YouTube channel in late 2009 through
to like 2010 or something, uh, 12, um,
she ended up getting a sort of, you know,
favorable reception with the progressive intelligence here were very feminist,
very pro social justice and they liked her patter because it's, um,
pretty stock, pretty pretty stock in trade and it's, and she was,
she came across as being very respectable. You know, she's well presented.
She's attractive, she's well-spoken. She, she knows her pastor and so they,
they promote her. They, you know, they made a big deal over,
she sounds like a total bigots when she's talking about anything they get
because she'll just say, well, this is men. I mean,
the whole premise of feminism is that men are oppressing women.
And if men aren't oppressing women, then feminism has no argument.
And they also have a sort of a thing they say to each other where you,
you have the rights to hate, your oppressor is right to do this. And it's like,
okay, but I don't think it's ever right to hate even if you aren't.
But this is something that she said personally know her personally.
She probably has said it personally, but this is the,
the sort of ideological thought. I mean, if you read the papers,
if you read the, if you read the to that they them thing again. Right. Okay.
They're talking about hardcore feminists.
We are talking about like a specific sphere of academic feminists in her case,
sex negative sex. [inaudible] yeah, they don't, they don't look,
they don't like objectification. Oh, they don't like sexy women and titties.
Sex negative. Yeah. They don't look sexy. Women. Um,
the male gaze is oppressing women Croft tomb Raider. Gotcha. Yeah. That was the,
that was part of the big issue, right. It was like sexism because of Lara Croft.
Terrible, terrible oppression. I don't know how women can get over it, but, uh,
any Stuckey's in stepped up and was like, you know,
it's wrong to look at these tits. And everyone was like,
but she's wearing a really tight top for a reason and she's not real. Yeah.
Uh, but yeah, so basically any he's in comes from a school of sex,
negative feminism and she decided that she would take advantage of all this.
Now in 2010 there was a video,
I think it was 2010 that the video was recorded in black and white of her a
university giving a speech where she says, I'm not a gamer.
I had to learn a lot about gaming to get into all this and then come 2012,
I mean that that video wasn't released until after she did her tropes versus
women in gaming. Kickstarter, 2012 May, 2012 she starts,
this starts and I was in within the first few days,
she starts posting updates on that I'm being harassed. And I said, well, yeah,
people generally react negatively to phenomenal bigots on the internet.
They don't like it. People don't like it. I mean,
when you say men are oppressing women and everything she says is a variant of
men are oppressing women, unit is the male gaze is highly oppressive to women.
Toxic masculinity is highly oppressive. Women's. Okay. When,
when can men legitimately look at women in eater? No answer. What is,
what is nontoxic masculinity? There's no such thing.
So what you're saying is masculinity and men checking out chicks is just bad and
you hate it.
And the men are all bad for doing this and they're oppressing the women.
They do this. Well,
that's why I said it seems like she's a bit of an opportunist.
She's got an angle and she realizes that there's a lot of attention that goes
towards that angle and she runs with it. I mean if I turned around and said,
well women,
a bunch of manipula manipulative slags who will take your money and run,
they'd be like, you're a fucking massage, but I gotta stop you there.
Cause I don't think she's ever said all men.
I don't think she said that she doesn't, she just uses the term men.
I don't think she does. I mean I really don't think she says she has.
That guy is her fucking head guy writes for [inaudible].
I know. I'm just doing now nothing basically this, this terrible thing.
But I, I want to, I want to set the record straight if you thinks, because this,
this is something that really annoys me. So, um,
I went to VidCon recently and VidCon. Yeah.
What is that YouTube convention in Anaheim sounded like a good time.
It was a really good time for me, but it wasn't,
it wasn't for them that their panels look like a bloody death March when they
spot a scene in the car. They like faces like, Oh God. I was like,
why do they get upset at you? Yeah.
Just cause we sat there listening to what they had to say. In fact,
if you heard about this, no opportunity, I'm insulated. Oh dude, this is crazy.
So any psyches in a,
she spots me sitting in the audience and then she starts freaking out.
Freaking out. Yeah. She starts, she starts saying things like,
there's a constant harasser of mine call me. You know,
she called me a shithead and she called me a garbage human, a garbage human.
I did nothing to her. I didn't say what,
I just sat in the audience while she's there cussing me out on the stage.
And I mean this now. So she's on the stage with a microphone.
She's calling you a shithead and the garbage human.
And this was because you have made videos about her. Is that what this is?
Because I've made videos debunking her points, like, and she,
she's under the impression that all of my videos are about her.
And I actually on the ride over, I got people to like count up for me. Uh, I've,
I've made around 30 videos in about four years. Referring to, and that's a lot.
No, no, no. It sounds nice. I did. It sounds like a lot,
but that's less than 4% of the videos I've made. I've made 780 videos.
I work hard. I'm sure you do. But that's still 30 videos.
I don't care if you've made 100 million videos,
you still make 30 videos about her. That's a large number. You know,
maybe it's a large number compared to Anita who hardly does any bloody work.
But, but that's, that's another interesting point. But what's,
what's interesting about it is if someone puts something out there, you know,
you're gonna get expect that someone is going to come along,
especially a guy like you that is very opinionated.
And if someone has very different opinions in yours,
you are going to have a contrary point. Of course,
that's definitely not harassing if you don't help me, but can't be,
we're in a scary position is exemplifying how are you harassing? Like what,
what was the gun? That's the thing.
That's the worst thing you've ever said about her, that she's wrong.
That's right. Yeah. Well. Yeah, I mean, she's, she,
you will never find someone who says she's a, she's a good critic.
She's a terrible critic and she always has been. She's always been,
it's always been rightly pointed out to her that she's cherry-picked every time.
No one stands by her work.
She's become like a symbol of feminism because of all the harassment she's
received. Now that is a part of the problem, right? That culture, very strange.
You don't get any props unless someone's sending you horrible messages.
And then a lot of people have been caught doing it to themselves,
which is really fucked up loads like the black lives matter activists and
whatnot. But yeah, so basically she's, her work sucks. It's just bad work.
I mean, nobody in the video game industry, we turn around and say,
you know what, that's great criticism. Need to only,
only like the progressive press. What black lives matter. Oh, it was,
it was ages go to a protest.
They basically had run around into the university's compute system,
logged into a fake Twitter account or something, send themselves a bomb threat.
And the police tracked it down and they're like,
we have the video camera footage. Yeah, it was,
it was actually really funny or so funny with there need to be a victim. Well,
it's, it validates them. Yeah, it really does. When you don't have an argument,
you need to be a victim. Well, does she expect that somehow?
I know that she's going to be able to put these points out and not have anybody
dispute these points. Oh, I'm guessing so. And she always,
she always conflates all criticism with harassment.
She's never addressed the critic. And the first time she addresses a critic,
it's me and she's calling me names. Yeah. That's not a good level. Yeah.
It's not, not very good. It's not a good look. She says,
she says that I'm responsible for all of the harassment now. All of it. Well,
at least it's definitely not hers. That's not her fault. No.
It's a controversial opinion and someone disputes it.
That person disputes it as responsible for all the harassment. Well, basically,
I've, I've always, I've always said front right from the get go,
don't have a contact them. Don't ever contact them because for a start, I mean,
they don't want to listen. She's not interested in hearing your fucking opinion.
So both, she's got nothing but contempt for you. But secondly,
don't send a harassment because a, it's a moral and B,
she's got the victim card that gives her money when she, when you go,
when you send her a message saying, Hey, neither, I think you're a bitch.
She goes, chick Ching, you know,
and then she runs off to the next interview where that she gets paid. I mean,
so some of her speeches at university, she's been paid 20 grand a speech.
I'm not joking. Right. And it's just, and for her to go,
the internet is being mean to me. Well,
maybe if you want to be in a bigger online, they wouldn't be.
Maybe if we actually did some solid work and didn't say video games and making
everyone sexist, which obviously not, this wouldn't be happening to you.
But the thing that pisses me off most about the accusations towards me of
harassment, apart from the fact that I've never harassed her,
and if there was any evidence,
I'd harassed that it'd be all over the internet right now. You know what I mean?
You,
it would be nothing but Twix bars because they trying to paint me as a harasser
when I'm actually just a critic oppose and I've always been completely against
it. But what really annoys me is that her Kickstarter, if you look at it now,
if you get go to it,
you can pull it up now and you can see tropes versus women and like, you know,
she's got a spill and then, Oh, the terrible messages, the harassment,
the harassment. That was in May,
2012 I didn't make a video on YouTube until July,
2013 this has been happening to her.
Her whole career is nothing to do with me is to do with her.
It's because she's a Dick. Everyone can see it.
And I had to call a girl Dick, like gall guy pussy. Yeah, I'm culinary a Dick.
You're a Dick. Anything looked into the camera. That's harassment.
Do you want to know something?
I've spoken to a lot of interesting people recently since I've been here,
lots of people who know you personally,
an eater and they say everyone hates you because you're a Dick.
Oh,
this is again mean you should have seen the article she put up about me today.
Another one. Well, yeah, just calling me harassing and all this stuff.
It's like, no, you're a Dick, Anita. Yes. Be in it.
Did you find a video of her saying that there's no biological difference between
the sexes and that there'll be buried in the middle of [inaudible]?
I really think that it was her, now that I'm thinking about it, I've, I've,
I've looked at it as well, maybe she took it down or something,
so I remember seeing it. I wish I'd say someone's got to save it.
Someone on the internet will be able to tweet to ass or something because it's
so hilarious because it's so contrary to biology, just actual science.
Everything she says is contrary to reality. I mean,
she'll sit there and she'll pick out like, I like the game Hitman in her video,
she said something like, uh, you're incentivized to, to kill the woman.
Then they stuff her body in a trunk and the footage she's using,
she didn't take herself. Obviously it didn't credit.
Whoever took it in the footage she's using, you see like the,
the guy go up and kill the go and you see them lose points. I said, no,
that's a disincentive realization. You know, that they're not incentivizing you.
They're saying that penalizing you for this. Anita, you UJ I mean,
I thought my very first video was to in eater as well,
and our very first video was like July,
2013 and I [inaudible] started off because of her.
We were inspired. Well, kind of, but there was a lot of things that kind of,
you know, that were going on. I was like, you know, I,
I feel the need to say something just, uh,
but apart from the quality being terrible, I'm bewildered at her.
I listened to her the other day and I was just like, wow,
I had no idea what was going on. And I was just like, he said,
I think you're just wrong on this. I think you,
I don't think you understand like the, there is a lot to this that you, you've,
you've left out, I should have said cherry picked, but you know, and that's,
that's something that's dog to hell. Correct. Cause that's all she's ever done.
Her Chris's is terrible and everyone knows it.
Nobody likes it because she's a divisive bitch and all she does is play the
victim. She's got nothing, she has nothing and all she does,
as long as it's not talking about her and specifically because we're,
we're kind of beating her down here.
But it's hard to think of anything genuinely good about her talking about her.
I mean,
what I'm saying is about these ideas instead of concentrating on her as a
person, that's the point.
They'd been debunked a million times all over the internet by everyone and their
mother at this point. I do. I, well, why do I want to get to,
what's interesting to me is what causes these people to group up into these
weird sort of echo chambers.
They start reiterating things that don't really work or make sense.
Like there's no biological difference between men and women,
especially when it comes to strength. There's,
and then the tropes about video games and also like here's the other thing,
like when that Gamergate thing happened, yeah, it was,
it was really fascinating to me that everybody wanted to absolutely lump people
in one or two categories and the two categories of people that are appalled to
it, appalled by it and that think that, you know,
sexism is a Boren and all this stuff is terrible.
And then the other people who supposedly if you,
if you wanted some sexy images and video games, you had to be a piece of shit.
Oh yeah. Like if he's likes negative feminists, Oh yeah. Well that,
but it got into this weird category where people were like, Hey,
we don't want you meddling with, with art.
And whether it's a Frank visit up censoring it. Yeah. I mean, look,
if you look at some of Frazetta stuff with the girls at the bikinis and swords
and familiar, but I mean famous fantasy artists.
Oh well we sort of like talking about like the eighties yes. Oral earlier,
beautifully painted. These oiled barbarians.
It's a celebration of the human fizzy cause there's perfect presentive. Yes,
yes, yes.
It's all Robert Howard's books on Conan and Frazetta was like the most famous of
the, yeah, it was,
but it's very cartoonish depictions of women with giant tits and Brian blood all
over the place and it's silliness doesn't make you hate women.
That's what's gross.
Like just like looking at Fabio on the cover of a romance novel doesn't mean you
hate men. Yeah, right. In fact, it seems you're kind of lionizing them. Look,
this is, this is the perfect depiction of what the artist wanted.
See like a man looked like in a huge rippling hero carrying the maiden or
whatever. But it becomes this weird thing when it's a man.
People don't have a problem with it. No one says that.
A demonizes the male figure and that you know that you have set these unnatural
standards, so you fucked with the self esteem of all these young men,
but you absolutely have in the same way you do it with women like body shaming
or you know, having ridiculous standards for bodies for females.
That works with men too. It's the same, yeah, of course does, but the led kit,
because feminists I called tamales.
The world is women being oppressed and men the oppresses and it's okay to hate
your oppressor. That's the, that's the root of all feminist thought.
But that's why I want to talk about this in terms of the ideas because I think
it's kind of the same thing as the right versus the left.
And I think it's all like a symptom of human psychology.
The right versus the left is tribalism. It is tribalism,
but so it's female versus male. It's, it's these,
when you look at this blind allegiance towards anyone with a vagina,
it's very similar to someone who is blind allegiance to is anyone who is in a
red state. This VidCon thing that you went to, what?
Who puts this together? Hankin John Green. And who are they?
The vlog brothers. They're famous YouTubers. And uh,
I find it very interesting when Anita was calling me a shithead and garbage
human, that's a direct violation of that code of conduct.
And did I do anything about it? No,
because she's a feminist because she's a woman. Oh. Because she gets special.
It's because she's in the,
he's in because she gets special treatment because at this point she's basically
become the avatar feminism. If she fails, I swear to God I didn't that,
I mean she respected in that world. No, no, no. Everyone hates her.
Why did they still prop her up? Because she's an Esau.
Keizan if she doesn't make any sense, why not? I mean, well,
there's a myth OS that's built up around her and get word. Yes.
It's, um, and they've all propped her up.
They've all propped her up level, said good things about her.
They've all defended her. And if it turns out that she is in fact an abuser,
which she did according to the VidCon code of conduct,
which is what is the code of conduct. Oh, I can't remember it verbatim,
but I read out a video. Uh, it's one of my latest videos. Um,
it was just a quick message to Hank and John Green. And, uh,
I know that thousands of people email them saying, Hey, look,
she did violate your code of conduct from a position of institutional privilege
at VidCon. She was on the panel. I didn't have a microphone.
She had a microphone. She's calling me names.
She's accusing me of things on true.
She was doing that while you were in the audience directly looking me in the
eye. And it was like, okay, that's fine. But, uh,
that's not right. And they've done nothing. They have done nothing.
They've said nothing. And then afterwards,
all I got from her fans and, and I mean like, you know,
hundreds and hundreds of messages,
and I've just retweeted them all night with exactly the same language she uses
when she's displaying. Oh,
look at the nasty messages I'm guessing of people calling me a garbage human,
which is what she'd called me. And so she has done absolutely nothing different.
And so I said right hand can John, she's violated your code of conduct.
Her fans, she's incited a cyber mob. Harassers exactly as she claims I do.
But she has actually done this. Then on the Saturday,
she was due to be on a panel about cyber harassment.
See? But he can't be harassment when she's a woman.
And you're a man because you are the oppressor.
So it's the same thing as racism,
like the black person being racist against a white person possible.
But the only,
the only reason to do this then to not to take no action is if you are highly
ideological and in. Interesting.
So you feel like they're high D I highly ideological, incredibly biased.
But why are they, if they're YouTube stars, I mean, aren't they like,
don't they understand? They're very progressive, very progressive.
You're fairly progressive too. I'm a liberal. I'm not progressive.
What is the difference between a liberal,
a liberal and cruelty of opportunity or progressive
wants? Quality of outcome. Quality of out
[inaudible].